[موسيقى]
عرف بالتعدد في مجالاته فقد كان رائدا
بالكثير من الاعمال سواء على الصعيد
العلمي او الادبي من الابحاث للاكتشافات
حتى الجوائز التي حصل عليها بالكتب والشعر
شعره بالحياه كن انت المفترق فلا يكونن ما
بعدك كما ما كان قبلك متحدثنا التالي ترك
بصمته بكل هذه الاعمال والميادين فمن غير
المفاجئ ان يسطع نجمه اليوم بحديثه الشيق
بعنوان بين الترجمه والتعريب والتغريب
رحبوا معنا باحد اهم الدكاتره والباحثين
في مجال طب الاسنان على مستوى سوريا
والعالم الاستاذ الدكتور نبيل نادر قوشجي
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم مرحبا انا نبيل قوسجي نبيل
ابن نادر قوسزي حاكيكم اليوم عن هل ثلاث
كلمات
هناك مقوله تنسب لابن حزم الاندلسي الرجل
الذي الف طوق الحمامه تقول المقوله الحكم
على الشيء فرع من تصوره ولكي نتصور شيئا
علينا ان ندخله كخيال مجرد في ادمغتنا
فاذا اردت ان انقل هذه الصوره علي ان احول
الصوره الى احرف منطوقه تعبر من دماغي الى
لساني الى اذانكم ليعاد لتعيد ادمغتكم
ترجمتها فتتحول الصوره منقوله من دماغي
الى ادمغتكم هذا ما يفعله جهاز الهاتف في
جيبي وجيبك وجيبك هذا ما يفعله تماما ينقل
بيانات
يحللها
يفكفكها ثم ينقلها من مكان الى مكان اخر
اذا علينا قبل ان نتحدث عن الترجمه
والتعريب وحتى التغريب علينا ان نعرف ان
هناك احرفا
تحولون كلمات المجرده الى معان او الى
مصطلح
ولان الله خلقنا شعوبا وقبائلا فقد تعددت
السنتنا ولان الله خلقنا شعوبا وقبائل
لنتعارف فعلينا ان نجد اليه لنقل المصطلح
من لسان الى لسان
هذا ما تعنى به الترجمه فالترجمه تعني ان
اردنا تعريفا مدرسيا لها الترجمه تعني ان
انقل نصا مكتوبا ومقروءا او
منطوقا ومسموعا من لسان الى لسان اخر
على ايه حال قد ينقل النص الواحد
باكثر من طريقه عبر اكثر من ترجمان وهذا
المثال الذي ساعطيكم اياه مثال ساطع لذلك
فقد كتب رجل اسمه عمر الخيام منذ مئات
السنين نصا اسماه رباعيات الخيام كتبه
بالفارسيه نقل الى العربيه اكثر من 50 مره
لعل اشهر نقلين له او ترجمتين هما ترجمه
احمد صافي النجفي
وترجمه احمد رامي
المعنيون بالادب يقولون ان ترجمه احمد
صافي النجفي لي رباعيات الخيام اكثر جزاله
وعذوبه ومع ذلك فترجمه احمد رامي اكثر
شهره
ان اردنا ان نفسر الفكره الاولى فنقول ان
احمد صافي النجفي نقل النص الفارسي الى
اللغه العربيه مباشره فهو كان يتقن
اللغتين بينما استعان احمد رامي بلغه
وسيطه بلسان وسيط فنقل من الفارسيه الى
الفرنسيه نقلت له ثم نقلها الى العربيه
وقرات بالامس انه نقلمها من الانجليزيه
على ايه حال اللغه الوسيطه اضعفت المعنى
اللسان الوسيط اضعف المعنى ولكنه اكثر
شهره لاننا كلنا ندندن مع ام كلثوم سمعت
صوتا هاتفا في السحر نادى من الغيب غفاه
البشر نعم
باتت في اذاننا لاننا سمعناها من ام كلثوم
ساخرج عن الترجمه واقول لكم لو جئنا بكلمه
عمرها الاف السنين البثولوجي واردنا ان
نحلل هذا المقطع الصوتي اقول لكم انها
كلمه اغريقيه مكونه من مقطعين باثول
تعني بالاغريقيه القديمه المغرقه بالقدم
للقدم الالم
ثم اصطلح على ان تكون اسما للمرض لان
الانسان في ذاك العصر لم يكن يخشى من
المرضي سوى شيئا واحدا وهو
الالم
فاصلح على ان بيثولوجي هي الالم والعلم ثم
جيء بها لتترجم وقبل ان يؤتى بها الى
الترجمه نعرف ان البتولوجي هي بحر واسع
جدا جدا جدا متعدد هي محيط متعدد الابحر
منه الاناتموبيولوجي فترجمت البثولوجي الى
التشريح المرضي ولو قلت لاي عربي غير دارس
للطب او بعيدا عن مجالي الكليات الطبيه
لقلت له انني مختص بالتشريح المرضي لازال
في ذهنه اول ما يجول انني اتحدث عن تشريح
الجثث
وليس ذاك المعنى المطلوب ثم جاء تعريب
تعريب مبدع للمصطلح فقيل البتولوجي هي علم
الامراض فاذا قلت لكم ان الرجل الواقف
امامكم يعنى بعلم الامراض ومختص به
فستعلمون ان الامراض وهي امر واسع جدا طيف
واسع جدا هي علم وهذا الرجل يتقن الخوض في
عظامه
فاذا جئنا الى التغريب وقلت لاحدهم انني
معني بالبتولوجيا فسيقف الرجل ويبتعد
قليلا وربما يقول اللهم ان هذا منكر
لارضاه
لانني لم انقل له الصوره من دماغي الى
دماغه او ربما كان اكثرها لعن فراحه عينيه
تدور في مقلتيه وهو يقول دستور لا من
ازيكم
واذا اردت ان اختمه بعيدا عن الالم
والامراض فسادحفكم بشيء هناك مثل انجليزي
يقول ومن باودر ذير فيسز
باودر فاذا اردت ان افكك الصوره فاقول ومن
نساء باودر مسحوق بودره
وجوههن وايل بينما فيما ظرفيه من الرجال
فيس يواجهون باودر البارود فاذا اردت ان
اصيغها مترجمه اقول
تضع النساء المساحيق على وجوههن فيما
يواجه الرجال البارود هذه ترجمه مكتمله
الاركان لكن ان اردت ان اعربها فساقول لكم
فيما تتجمل النساء يواجه الرجال الحديد
والنار
وستعرف كاي عربي ان الجمله الثانيه الطفوا
واجزلوا واشد وقعا في قلبك لانها تلامس
شغاف قلبك اما ان اردت ان تكون اديبا
طبيبا فستقول في عجاله هناك مرادف للمعنى
عربي قبل المثل الانجليزي الذي عمره 200
عام او يزيد او ينقص هناك شاعر عربي قبل
1500 عام قال بيت الشعر التالي قال ان
الكرام على الجياد مبيتهم فدعي الرماح
لاهلها وتعطري
مساؤكم
عطور وعبق زهور وابتسامه حبور
تطفي على الانفس انفس الشعور السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]